[Musique]
ils seront 8 à s'envoler vers les
Seychelles pour 3 semaines de stage ces
apprentis de l'urma de Sainte-Clotilde
spécialisée dans la boulangerie
pâtisserie ont été invités ce mardi 4
octobre à récupérer leur billet d'avion
et leur kit de départ au palais de la
source développer la coopération
régionale et soutenir dans le même temps
la mobilité des jeunes Réunionnais c'est
le but de ce projet encadré par une
convention tripartite signée par le
Conseil départemental la Chambre des
Métiers et le Seychelles théoriesm
Academy la coopération avec les pays de
la zone Océan Indien est un des axes
forts de notre mandature 2022 2028 au
titre de la coopération la chambre de
métier le président Bernard Picardo nous
a sollicité pour que l'on puisse
accompagner une belle opération faisant
en sorte que des jeunes Réunionnais dans
les métiers de la boulangerie et la
pâtisserie puisse aller aussi se former
aux Seychelles c'est ce que nous avons
accepté et aujourd'hui donc nous sommes
à la première phase de cette opération
c'est la remise donc de pieds d'avion
qui quitte
tunique de travail et lorsque ces jeunes
vont partir il faut se dire une chose
c'est que c'est la Réunion qui gagne
c'est la réunion à travers sa jeunesse
anthropologue qui se projette et qui
demeure et bien reviendront ici à la
Réunion enrichi de ces belles
expériences et donc c'est une belle
opération
d'assiation par l'activité économique
qui est menée en lien avec la chambre de
métiers de l'artisanat exercices au 27
octobre les apprentis seront répartis
dans trois hôtels de luxe 5 étoiles une
expérience bénéfique pour ces jeunes
soutenus par leurs employeurs
réunionnais alors il a été très content
de cette nouvelle il m'a dit il m'a
encouragé à partir
c'est une bonne expérience voilà donc je
vais faire honneur je vais profiter au
maximum et puis j'en ai à la chance
de pouvoir travailler dans des étoiles
des restaurants 5 étoiles des hôtels 5
étoiles on n'a pas à la Réunion on va on
va reparler anglais on va travailler
avec des étrangers ça va être
beaucoup de nouvelles compétences qu'on
va apprendre dans le milieu hôtelier
comparer à la boulangerie qu'on a à la
Réunion c'est c'est l'occasion d'aller
aux Seychelles aussi parce que j'aurais
pas pu le faire
les propres moyens le truc c'est
vraiment bien comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure pas tout le monde à la chance de
voyager et
qu'on expériences et j'espère que
profiter au maximum là-bas l'enveloppe
globale de ce projet se porte à
83414 euros dont 26916 financées par le
département de La Réunion
[Musique]